one month ago dr fauci announced that he
would retire by the end of joe biden's
term as president which would have put
that somewhere around the year 2024.
yesterday fauci dramatically moved up
the timetable in a written statement he
announced
i will be stepping down from the
positions of director of the national
institute of allergy and infectious
diseases
niaid and chief of the niaid laboratory
of immunoregulation
as well as the position of chief medical
advisor to president joe biden
now for the millions of americans whose
life fauci almost single-handedly
upended in some cases destroyed over the
past few years this announcement was
good
and welcome
and unexpected news
but much like the hiv virus that fauci
botched and bungled for decades
dr fauci
does not simply go away
his statement continued
i will be leaving these positions in
december of this year to pursue the next
chapter of my career
while i am moving on from my current
positions i am not retiring
after more than 50 years of government
service i plan to pursue the next phase
of my career while i still have so much
energy and passion for my field
now i knew fauci would never actually
voluntarily retire he loves power he
loves controlling people
and he loves seeing his own face on tv
fauci was a little bit vague about what
he's considering for the next phase of
his career i for one think that he
should become the director of the wuhan
institute of virology he's clearly on
great terms with that laboratory he's
secretly funded research there including
gain of function research and then he
lied about it when he became
when it became clear rather that gain of
function research at the wuhan lab
almost certainly caused the global
pandemic it would be the ultimate troll
and flaunting of unaccountable power for
a man who loves both and most
importantly it would probably do dr
fauci some good to get as far away from
washington dc as possible because the
only reason that he accelerated his
plans to leave the nih is because he
thinks republicans are going to win back
the congress and he knows that
republicans are pledging to make a big
show
of investigating him and he knows that
he's got four decades of incompetence
and lies and deceit to answer for right
now head on over to ahs.com
knowles we could all use some peace of
mind when it comes to staying on budget
right now especially when it comes to
your home keep your budget goals in
check with american homeshield they
offer a choice of three great plans to
help cover the cost to repair or replace
parts of your major home systems and
appliances both new and old if american
home shield can't repair a covered item
they will replace it from hvac systems
and plumbing to kitchen appliances their
plans help protect parts of up to 23
essential home systems and appliances
electronics coverage available for an
unlimited number of eligible items such
as smart watches flat screen tvs and
more other options include roof leak
repair and pool and spa coverage
coverage available no matter how old
your systems and appliances are plus
they're offering an exclusive 50 bucks
off to our listeners keep your home up
and running and budget on track with
american home shield right now our
listeners can take 50 bucks off their
most comprehensive plans ever ahs.com
knowles to save 50 bucks that's ahs.com
slash knowles for 50 bucks off any plan
american home shield be sure with the
shield service fees limitations and
exclusions apply c plan for details
voucher thinks he's going to get away
with it
maybe he will i don't know
i hope he doesn't
but republicans get squishy and then
they just move on to the next shiny
object republicans they're going to see
a little butterfly and just get totally
distracted and lose sight of what they
were supposed to be focusing on which is
punishing dr fauci and getting getting
to the bottom of all of his incompetence
and the deceit and how he screwed up
people's lives for three years
two and a half years rand paul says he's
not going to get away with it he says
quote fouch's resignation will not
prevent a full-throated investigation
into the origins of the pandemic it will
be asked to testify under oath regarding
any discussions he participated in
concerning the lab league
which i hope is true senator paul has
been great on the fouchy issue so far
he's grilled him and owned him with
facts and logic in the senate but we've
really got to stick to this do not let
him
sneak away fauci actually said this when
he announced a month ago that he would
be
stepping down by the end of biden's term
he actually said one of the reasons he
was doing that is because it will make
it less likely that the republicans will
investigate him i went to look back for
that clip because it was a public clip i
remember seeing it and like so many of
dr fatchi's clips it's really hard to
find on the internet right now they just
sort of disappear a lot of these clips i
i can only go back and find them on my
show
because the original source clips they
just get memory hold on the internet but
it's really important
this man
destroyed people's lives
the two and a half years of the coveted
lockdowns which were completely
unnecessary which were capricious and
arbitrary which punished one group of
people conservatives and allowed another
group of people the libs to do whatever
they wanted shut down churches shut down
grandma's funeral shut down your
business but leave open the the
marijuana dispensary leave open the blm
riots that you can't go you can't go to
the funerals for your family members but
george floyd he gets four funerals okay
just completely
arbitrary wielding of power
to attack the conservatives and to
reward the libs and it was being done
because of fauci's recommendations and
he's trying to weasel out of it dr
fatchi has come out and he said he said
listen listen here i never i never in
any way suggested we should lock down
the country
there were um authorities that made
different decisions than the cdc's
recommendations for example on school
closures and they did not see higher
levels of child mortality when it comes
to covet and meanwhile the schools that
did close down we're now seeing just
disastrous levels of learning loss among
poor children children of color mental
health crisis i wonder if you would
recommend locking down schools if you
had to do it all over again
well you know again it's first of all i
didn't recommend locking anything down
you you're asking me questions you're
talking about the cdc is the public
health agency that uses their
epidemiologist and their science-based
approach to make recommendations
i didn't recommend lagging anything down
you're lying don't stop saying that
about me okay so that's one perspective
now to give the opposite perspective
here is dr fauci
your reaction to rand paul and others
saying they're going to investigate you
if they take power
well there's there's no reason to do
that but if they want to go ahead my
records are an open book they are
talking about things that are really
bizarre john like crimes against
democracy by shutting down the
government all i have ever done and go
back and look at everything i've ever
done was to recommend common sense good
cdc recommended public health policies
that have saved millions of lives if you
want to investigate for me for that go
ahead
dr fauci
obviously recommended locking down the
country now he denies it because he
knows he's going to get in a lot of
trouble for that
so i hope if i hope the republicans
retake the house i hope they retake the
senate and i hope they just grill this
guy
he's not done even
they should grill him even if he were
just going to retire and go off into the
sunset but he says he's not going to do
that he wants to continue to wield power
and influence we should not
it would be a disgrace to the republican
party if we let him do that
i'm so glad you like those clips now
ring the bell subscribe we're gonna get
a billion subscribers we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you